[Music]
an enduring myth says we use only 10% of
our brain the other 90% standing idly by
for spare capacity hucksters promised to
unlock that hidden potential with
methods based on neuroscience but all
they really unlock is your wallet
two-thirds of the public and nearly half
of science teachers mistakenly believe
the 10% myth in the 1890s William James
the father of American psychology said
most of us do not meet our mental
potential James meant this as a
challenge not an indictment of scant
brain usage but the misunderstanding
stuck also scientists couldn't figure
out for a long time the purpose of our
massive frontal lobes or broad areas of
the parietal lobe damage didn't cause
motor or sensory deficits so authorities
concluded they didn't do anything for
decades these parts were called silent
areas their function elusive we've since
learned that they underscore executive
and integrative ability without which we
would hardly be human they're crucial to
abstract reasoning planning weighing
decisions and flexibly adapting to
circumstances the idea that nine-tenths
of your brain sits idly by in your skull
looks silly when we calculate how the
brain uses energy rodent and canine
brains consume 5% of total body energy
monkey brains use 10% an adult human
brain which accounts for only 2% of the
body's mass consumes 20% of daily
glucose burned in children that figure
is 50% and in infants 60% this is far
more than expected for their relative
brain sizes which scale in proportion to
body size human ones weigh 1.5 kilograms
elephant brains 5 kilograms and whale
brains 9 kilograms yet on a per weight
basis humans pack in more neurons than
any other species this dense packing is
what makes us so smart there is a
trade-off between body size and the
number of neurons a primate including us
can sustain a 25 kilogram ape has to eat
eight hours a day to uphold a brain with
53 billion neurons
the invention of cooking one and a half
million years ago gave us a huge
advantage cooked food is rendered soft
and predigested outside of the body our
guts more easily absorb its energy
cooking frees up time and provides more
energy than if we ate foodstuffs raw and
so we can sustain brains with 86 billion
densely packed neurons 40% more than the
ape here's how it works half the
calories of brain burns go towards
simply keeping the structure intact by
pumping sodium and potassium ions across
membranes to maintain an electrical
charge to do this the brain has to be an
energy hog it consumes an astounding 3.4
times 10 to the 21st power
ATP molecules per minute ATP being the
coal of the body's furnace the high cost
of maintaining resting potentials in all
86 billion neurons means that little
energy is left to propel signals down
axons and across synapses the nerve
discharges that actually get things done
even if only a tiny percentage of
neurons fired in a given region at any
one time
the energy burden of generating spikes
over the entire brain would be
unsustainable here's where energy
efficiency comes in letting just a small
proportion of cells signal at any one
time known as sparse coding uses the
least energy but carries the most
information because the small number of
signals have thousands of possible paths
by which to distribute themselves a
drawback of sparse coding within a huge
number of neurons is its cost worse if a
big proportion of cells never fire then
they are superfluous and evolution
should have jettisoned them long ago the
solution is to find the optimum
proportion of cells that the brain can
have active at once for maximum
efficiency between 1% and 16% of cells
should be active at any given moment
this is the energy limit we have to live
with in order to be conscious at all the
need to conserve resources is the reason
most of the brain's operations must
happen outside of consciousness it's why
multitasking is a fool's errand we
simply lack the energy to do two things
at once let alone three or five
when we try we do each task less well
than if we'd given it our full attention
the numbers are against us your brain is
already smart and powerful so powerful
that it needs a lot of power to stay
powerful and so smart that it has built
in an energy efficiency plan so don't
let a fraudulent myth make you guilty
about your supposedly lazy brain guilt
would be a waste of energy
after all this don't you realize it's
dumb to waste mental energy you have
billions of power-hungry neurons to
maintain so hop to it
[Music]